tonight's talk is is is one of my
favorite kinds of talk it's actually
three of my favorite kinds of talk all
in one and and one is it's a talk that
takes science fiction seriously it's
something that's really important to us
here at Long now we think that science
fiction is actually one of our key ways
of thinking about the future and having
conversations about the future and in in
in this talk we're going to find out
it's not just science fiction but
fiction in general that's that's really
important so it's it's that favorite
kind of talk another favorite kind of
talk is that it's a work in progress and
it's it's not just a work in process we
have a lot of great talks that are
speakers that have written a book and
they're doing a book tour and they've
they've talked about their book and all
these different cities when they come
here hopefully it's it's a it's a little
bit unique being in this room and with a
long-term thinking perspective on it
it's something that's different on a
talk that they've given a lot of times
this is the first time this talk has
been given there's maybe one proto
version of it that was done but a lot of
the work that tonight's speaker has done
is is for this audience and for for the
audience watching later and for you know
so future work that's going to be done
on this project so that means it's not
finished it hasn't been he is very much
still working on it there's gonna be a
lot of other feedback and and our
feedback in this room is actually gonna
influence where this goes so no pressure
on your QA okay so so that's the second
favorite kind of talk and also just
something to keep in mind as we're doing
this that you know not all the answers
are there yet but but asking the
questions might might be really key to
the evolution of this idea the third
favorite kind of talk is it's a Phil
Miller face James Holland Jones
tonight's speaker this is actually the
third time he's been on this stage and
he's talked about diverse topics first
before and
hee hee is a and and earth he's a earth
science earth science a North System
scientist I said that right ok their
system scientists and he is a an
anthropologist biological anthropologist
I believe and so that right too and you
know I always say about Jaime and and
you're gonna really see it tonight it's
it's this diversity of disciplines this
wide range of expertise all kind of
brought together with a serious rigor to
even areas that are not his native
ground as it were and it's something
really special in store for you tonight
so please join me give a big round of
applause for mr. James Holland John's
tonight's speaker thanks Michael that's
really very kind I have in fact given
this talk a prototype of a talk I gave
it on shipboard in the Galapagos Islands
and we were at we were actually actually
under steam when we did it and so and I
was right in the bow and I literally was
was running from side to side as we were
pitching so I'm hoping the ground will
be a little more stable tonight this is
not something I'm literature it's not
something I'm really an expert on at all
I'm not a literary guy I'm very much a
scientist and a funny story when I first
went to Stanford I was being recruited
and they asked me if I could teach a
human nature class I was like human
nature absolutely that's my bread and
butter that's what I did I taught that
every semester as a grad student no
problem I got this I show up at Stanford
I meet with this guy in the German
department who's going to talk to me
about my human nature class I thought
that's odd why would someone in the
German department want to talk to me
about human nature it turns out that I
had signed up to teach for this program
called the introduction to the
humanities program which had these rules
like you had to read five books and they
were supposed to be great books it was
sort of a great books kind of curriculum
I was like five books in one semester
okay I think I've read five books before
sure I can do that you know typically I
tend to read papers that are like three
pages long
that's you know that's kind of the
nature of science I managed to do it I
paired with a historian we had a great
class
so tonight rather than talking deeply
about the literature I'm gonna talk
about what I know more about which is
the science and I'm gonna talk about a
bunch of different varieties of science
here I've been warned that you know I'm
preaching to the choir when I talk about
climate change but I can't help myself I
need to talk a little bit about it this
is this is Sao Paulo it's a city of oh
my notes right here of 12 million people
it is on a coastal plain as are
three-quarters of the world's mega
cities these are cities over 10 million
people are on coastal plains okay forty
percent of the world's population as it
currently stands 40 percent of seven and
a half billion people live within 100
kilometers of the coast
this is Dhaka oh that's not that good
this is dakka dakka is a city of 19
million people it is not coastal however
it lies on a triangle in between three
rivers and the rivers all flood annually
during the lawn soon season
by the end of the century 50% of
Bangladesh which bear-
is the size of New York State it's one
hundred and forty seven thousand square
kilometers it's the size of New York
State it has a currently 163 million
people in it
50% of the land area is going to be
inundated by the end of the century okay
New York City average height above sea
level is 33 feet the highest point is
265 feet it is I don't actually know how
many of you I know how many people are
in Dhaka I don't know how many are in
New York City
a lot yeah seven million okay thank you
all right seven million apparently a lot
of people and living in a very
vulnerable spot we currently have an
administration that our the president
who famously and I don't know I don't
quite know what the right word for it is
I he famously doesn't care about science
is disdainful of science doesn't want to
hear from scientists despite the fact
that we have a growing body of evidence
for our own very senses we have you know
images of floods right this is the
interstate in Houston right we have the
tragic fires that we've experienced so
near by ourselves here right as an
anthropologist as a demographer as
someone who thinks about human
interactions with the climate I think
about people in motion
climate change will put people in motion
and the the great Pakistani author
motion Hamid you know talks about he
says we are all people in motion right
we're constantly moving we're coming and
going so I probably got the quote wrong
by the way cuz my notes aren't here but
that was one of those things we were
supposed to look at when we great thank
you I don't need them that much but for
quotes I do turns out it's we are all
migrants we moved through space and time
right and and in in a different talk in
a talk where I was talking in a more
disciplinary we're talking to you as an
anthropologist talking about
anthropological topics I would talk
about how one of the fundamental
features of the human adaptation we are
the mobile species when things get bad
we it turns out we move around a lot in
our home ranges compared to other things
that are similar
to us like chimpanzees or that we're
closely related to but when things get
really bad for us we just up and move
continents and we stay there it's a
remarkable thing that we do right so we
have a history from the very outset of
Homo sapiens of being mobile primates
okay and I would suggest you that
mobility will be the number one social
issue related to climate change related
to pretty much anything in the 21st
century going forward people are fleeing
conflict people are fleeing droughts and
the collapse of subsistence farming
people are fleeing both and this is this
is a fundamental part of my work right
now and I'm going to talk to you briefly
about that after I show you my summary
slide for the talk I like to show the
summary at the beginning because we all
think we're gonna build this great
narrative arc and we have this dana mall
and everyone's gonna be hanging on their
edge of their seat and they're gonna
tell you oh wow i get it now it turns
out it's way better to tell people what
you're gonna tell them at the outset so
I'm about to do that okay um I have four
points that I'm going to make two of
them I call them factual and two of them
I call them instrumental as in I care
about doing something about climate
change
I would like to use stories to encourage
other people to do things about climate
change okay the first factual point is
that fiction provides a powerful tool
for modeling complex systems and this is
where my science comes in I'll talk
about what I mean by a complex system in
a minute and give you a couple sort of
passing examples to what I think
narrative can do in fiction can do
stories are more effective than facts at
changing people's minds you can throw
facts at people you can throw facts at
the president right and they're not
going to change their mind
but stories have a chance to they have
to be the right stories they have to be
pitched correctly they have to be
compelling but they give us a tool for
for changing in people's minds and
that's a
actual point an instrumental point right
is that fiction allows us to imagine
better worlds this is another motion
Hamid point and I think it's really
important I think it's difficult to
overstate how important this is for
moving forward and secondly I think we
need a broad diversity of stories and
there's a really interesting bunch of
literature that I'll talk about a little
bit in the neuroscience of storytelling
and and listening to stories that
supports this idea that we need a broad
diversity of stories of forms of voices
of people talking about climate change
all right so I think that narrative is a
great way and particularly long-form
narrative is a great way to model
complex systems what do we mean by a
complex system the canonical model of
lynxes and hares yeah I don't need to
point to them you know these it's a it's
a fairly simple ecosystem in in northern
climes in Canada
we've got lynxes on the right eat hares
and what we see is in the both
empirically and theoretically the they
tend to cycle right and they cycle off
in in periods that don't that don't
completely aligned with each other when
the hares in the red are very abundant
right
the Lynx population grows it grows so
high that it causes the hare population
to crash the hare population crashes and
then there's a little bit of a lag and
the Lynx population crashes because
there are no Harris feet and we keep
doing this forever in the theoretical
model we don't do this forever in
reality I like to represent these things
in what's called the phase plane so this
is a time series they're plotted again
they're each population is plotted
against time here we take time out we
make it implicit and we plot the the
Predators against the prey
population okay and it's it's sort of a
I don't know a nicer way I think to
visualize this so Alan Hastings is a
theoretical ecologist amazing
theoretical ecologist up at the
University of California Davis and
sometime in the early 90s he was
interested in chaos he works with
predator prey models and these sorts of
things and he added a single species to
the classic this is called the lock of
Volterra model of predator prey model
yet a single species with realistic
parameters so you know the like
consumption rates the mortality rates
all the sort of biological parameters
that go into it and what do we get
we've got something that looks like this
now we have three species that we have
to plot against each other in their face
planes but we have everything gets
really crazy we go from clock-like
regularity to something that is in fact
chaotic right so my my auto drawing yeah
and so the things about complexity that
come out of this is that you have
tightly coupled systems right when you
only have one predator and one prey
they're very tightly coupled the ones
livelihood depends on the other we put a
third thing in there and and it kind of
throws everything off it's still tightly
coupled it's also very nonlinear right
so the the things can change very
rapidly in certain regimes and when you
put those two things together you have
the possibility for depending on just
what the right number of things are
together you get very different outcomes
and you get these crazy squiggly phase
phase planes this is a complex system
coupling non-linearity complexity very
difficult to make predictions on because
of the it ends up having a great
sensitivity to initial conditions so
this is the sort of thing that we work
on in my group and I'm going to tell you
a quick story about a pretty crazy line
of reasoning this here is
an artist rendition of the the bacterium
Neisseria gonorrhea they don't want to
guess what disease that causes it's an
amazing pathogen by the way it's I know
it sounds gross it's incredible
it's an incredible pathogen I'm happy to
talk at length about gonorrhea and it's
down I was down at in San Diego my son
goes to University of California San
Diego and I was at an event and he came
and he called me over to the table all
the parents had dispersed he called me
over to the table was a bunch of his
teammates and we're talking for maybe
three minutes and I say gonorrhea and
all the boys at the table a bunch of
twenty year old boys go yes and I'm like
what just get played and it's like yeah
you know I told them just watch you can
make them say gonorrhea so this is
gonorrhea this is nice and the work that
I'm doing with a collaborator Ashley
hazel who's another anthropologist
working working who's worked in my group
for a couple years now we suspect that
there we have a hypothesis that there's
a linkage between climate change and the
virulence of this pathogen like how bad
the disease it causes and there's it
seems kind of like a crazy idea the
place where we're working is Namibia in
the southwestern corner of Africa
there's the line so this is Namibia here
and the region that we're working in
Namibia is the driest country in
sub-saharan Africa the region that we're
working in is called caca veld it's up
here in the far northwest and it is the
driest region of Namibia
it is a dry place and unfortunately due
to the local effects of climate change
it has gotten considerably drier
southern Africa has had a protracted
drought of about six years and the
people who live there are exquisitely
adapted to a dry climate but the thing
found adaptations through a dry climate
is you have to have wet years in order
to make up for the bad the bad drought
years but when you have six drought
years in a row things start to go
asunder water is hard to find these are
pasture less people and and there so
we've got this historic drought what do
people do they respond they adapt and
they adapt the way people have adapted
for however long you want to define what
people are you I could make an argument
right two million years sixty thousand
years whatever you want to say right
whatever critter counts as human I'm
good with that we've been mobile from
that point forward they move okay the
past was people of Calca val responded
as people have always responded they
adapted by changing their mobility and
the thing about changed mobility is it
means that you make new contacts okay
you you move you encounter different
people you move around a greater
landscape you move differently you move
to places you've never seen you
encounter people you've never
encountered before and the epidemiology
of directly transmitted pathogens like
gonorrhea changes we typically use
mathematical models to explore how this
happens and this is just a simple
network model it's a it's a sexual
network where we have just a little bit
where people are actually moving for you
know on average about a week longer than
they normally do and you can just see
from left to right the the outbreak
cluster the outbreak is the red it's
bigger when people move more according
to the assumptions that we put into the
model so this is the way I normally
think about complex systems but a
there's always a story that we tell that
goes under this right and this is this
is the logic that links climate change
to gonorrhea virulence is it moves
through adaptation people going about
their livelihood business the social
effects of that and what that implies
for the transmission dynamics and then
what the transmission dynamics then
imply for the Selective forces on
virulence okay that's the complex system
we've got at least six different
subsystems linked there we tell stories
about it we use math we tell stories
when you write a novel you have to you
have to do engage in the process of
world building right and you have all
these linked systems in reality just I
mean this is we have a reality of course
but in in you know the New York City
reality of Kim Stanley Robinson's New
York 21:40 this is the cover art from
that from that book and sea levels have
risen by 50 years in a very short period
of time what does this mean for if
they've gone up by 50 feet for a city
that's on average 33 feet above sea
level what does this mean oh well you're
gonna have this super Venice that he
calls it right you've got you've got
flooding permanent flooding up to about
46th Street and what does that mean for
how people move about the city what does
that mean for in in a rapidly
decarbonizing economy where you don't
have long-distance transport that's as
easy what does that mean for food
production where do people get their
vegetables from where do people get
their produce from what does it mean for
the governance of small scale
organizations like an apartment co-op in
New York City right these are the types
of consequences you have a global change
you have the the the effects are felt
locally right and you have to play out
how all these things are going to work
right it's a model it's it's it's Kim
Stanley Robinson's opinion of what's
going to happen but I don't know I think
he's on to something in in most of these
things I know that Anna Lee Nuits spoke
recently about what was she talking
about science needs fiction and she had
such a fabulous example of how you have
to you have to come to grips with the
consequences of your narrative arc here
like okay so she's got this pirate in
the Arctic right who's on the internet a
lot on on shipboard and then she's like
Oh God where does she get the internet
from right and so she had to invent
something to the technology that
provides Internet in the Arctic and and
you know this is this is the notion you
have to flesh out these worlds you're
playing with complex systems it's
actually not a huge point I mean well
it's it's an important point but it's
not it doesn't need to be belabored I
you know this is a fan art for Paolo
Bacigalupi 'he's the the windup girl and
you know in a decarbonized world supply
chains are going to be highly altered
right how do you where do you get your
food from where's the energy to run
manufacturing where does that come from
or if you have if you have a an
industrial plant that produces whatever
the machines that you're trying to build
where do you get the power to run your
machinery right these are all things
that come out in in the windup girl so
that's point number one point number two
has to do with imagining the future and
imagining better worlds and again
there's this terrific motion Hamid quote
part of the great political crisis we
face in the world today is a failure to
imagine plausible desirable futures or
surrounded by nostalgic visions
violently nostalgic visions fiction can
imagine differently I think this is an
enormous ly important idea and I feel
like it probably resonates with anyone
who is dissatisfied say with the current
administration and politics in America
we really are feeling this incredibly
violent leanness nostalgic moment and
and typically these nostalgia z' are
four things that really didn't happen or
they certainly didn't happen the way we
remember them memory is it is an
imperfect process and so by writing
fiction we can imagine a better world
and I think this actually has really
important implications for the type of
fiction that we should write and and in
particular I I took all the slides out
of all the ridiculous movies
dealt with climate but there are lots of
them you don't have to like think very
hard about it and there what's the
commonality of them they're all
post-apocalyptic you know we love max
and water world and you know we didn't
love water world but we love the idea of
these are these are post-apocalyptic
stories and they're not better futures
maybe there's some hair you know Katniss
Everdeen or whoever you know comes in
and and does the heroic thing and and
that's that's interesting but it's not
we're not imagining a better world I
think we need to do better in imagining
better worlds and the thing is there's
plenty of fiction that does exactly that
so that's the good news now we have to
convince Hollywood and whoever makes TV
shows the great Indian novelist Amma
Tosh I'm at South Ghosh in addition to a
bunch of other literary intellectuals
Richard powers Robert McFarlane Bill
McKibben decry the lack of climate
themes in literary fiction and this is
something honestly I'm not quite that
worried about among other reasons I
think we have amazing literary fiction
that deals with climate change we have
Barbara Kingsolver 'z flight behavior we
have of course Richard powers himself
with sorry little sluggish with with the
overstory but I think that this this
sort of questioning of our are we
hitting the sweet spot for the the type
of fiction we should be writing raises
an important issue and this has to do
with the diversity of the story types
and the diversity of the voices who are
telling these stories I like science
fiction Michael like science fiction I'm
sure many people in this world like
science fiction not everybody likes
science fiction I don't understand why
but it's true and so if we have
different voices telling stories about
people dealing with the consequences of
a changed world we have a better chance
of actually reaching people there's a
very interesting body of work in
psychology and neuroscience on on the
neuroscience and the psychology of
changing people's minds and it turns out
that when you try to use a story to
change someone's mind in order to the
the degree of behavior change is
proportional to the degree to which the
reader or the viewer relates to the
central character okay so if you just
instrumentally if you want to change
people's behavior if you want to make
them concerned about climate change if
you want to encourage them to actually
take political action they have to read
the story and be able to relate to the
character it's just that simple
and so this argues very strongly I think
for casting as wide a net as we possibly
can in in fiction getting more diversity
a diversity of voices a diversity of
stories a diversity of characters so
that these these characters can resonate
with different groups of people I've
mentioned that we have great literary
fiction coming out I feel like we're
doing okay I can't recommend flight
behavior enough I lived in in Appalachia
for a while and so it really it really
read it's really not the type of book I
normally read I'm really more of a hard
science fiction reader
iris is it moves me it's amazing and and
Richard powers book I'm still the
overstory I'm still coming to grips with
it I finished it a year ago or whatever
the summer and I still it's messing with
my mind still you know I think about it
a lot but there you know there's such a
great cadre of
climate fiction writers so that I'm not
that concerned by I want to continue to
push people to think about this from
from different types of stories these
are more sort of the science fiction
types for the most part from the bottom
left Paolo Bacigalupi Margaret Atwood
Kim Stanley Robinson Octavia Butler some
some newer authors Sam Miller not as new
an author but need a climate fiction
Maggie Maggie G and of course San
Francisco zone and only knew it so
there's good news and great news is that
a lot of those books are back there that
you can peruse so I feel like the
fiction is healthy we need to push for
this diversity of stories that we can
have we are a highly social species the
term pro-social is used to describe the
the type of human sociality and joe
henrik anthropologist at harvard has
argued quite forcefully that the thing
that makes humans smart is not the fact
that we are individually smart people
it's the fact that we together are
amazing problem solvers we have a
collective intelligence that's that's
pretty unique and the way we go about
this is through social learning right we
learn about complex things through
through social learning we learn about
how to adapt to our world
through a process of social learning
where we imitate successful people we
have people who teach us we
we yeah we shamelessly copy you know
this whole idea monkey see monkey do
monkeys don't see and then do it's it's
actually a human thing it's it's it's
this idea of being able to copy
something it's it it's us it's not
monkeys it's it's I know it's meant to
be a put-down so a key element of social
learning is narrative we tell stories to
teach our children we tell stories to
teach teach each other and one of the
key capacities of learning through
narrative is that we have to be able to
take perspectives we have to be able to
take different perspectives and I'm
probably a necessary tool for taking
others perspectives is the capacity to
have thoughts about thoughts okay this
is called metacognition and when one has
thoughts about other people's thoughts
that's that's what's known as a theory
of mind okay and this is a it's a
cottage industry in comparative
psychology is figuring out do or wrong
towns have a theory of mind
they might chimpanzees don't gorillas
don't seem to right it's it's you know
it's it's put whatever you and I so the
the classic paradigm for testing apes by
the way is you you put them to sleep you
Nesta ties them and then you paint a
yellow dot on their forehead and you
give them a mirror and if when they wake
up kinda groggy they walk over to the
mirror and they go what is that right
then they have they have the self self
awareness it's probably not a perfect
paradigm like if you didn't if you just
don't care that there's a dot on your
forehead does it mean you're not
self-aware okay sorry
so the theory the theory of mind is
probably central to this adaptation that
we have it's learning through narrative
telling people stories and Darwin had
thoughts on this all sentient beings
developed through natural selection in
such a way that pleasant sensations
serve to guide and especially the
pleasure derived from sociability and
from loving our families right that that
that selection favors social goods being
pleasurable right and and drives us to
doing more things like that so theory of
mind is is probably a very important
part of what makes humans human it
allows us to learn socially and and a
big part of learning socially is about
telling stories that that teach us I'm
going to talk a little bit for the next
couple minutes on on some neuroscience
of storytelling and and and learning
about stories and you see my notes here
yep alright when you read a story and
we're gonna come back to the theory of
mind bit right it expertise in when you
read a story this is simply here to cue
me to say that we have the somato
sensory cortex runs right down along
here right along the postcentral gyrus
and you've seen it drawn as a homunculus
you know the the greatly exaggerated
hand and nose and mouth and the huge
lips right this is where all these
projections happen these are the the
parts of your brain that deal with with
with sensory perception and movement and
you're in your body when you read a
story and you're following along the
action of the character and you're
engaged in the story and that's a really
important caveat you have to actually be
engaged in the story
when you're engaged in the story and
you're reading along we see that
somatosensory cortex fires like crazy as
though you're living through the actions
and the feelings and the and the lived
experience of the character this is
really it's really interesting it's
really important you're not obviously
actually experiencing this and that and
this is actually it turns out to be very
very similar to dream state right when
when you're dreaming you're actually
your brain is actually sending signals
and you're flying by flapping your wings
or something
suppose you have wings your your your
brain is telling your arms to move but
they're not because you're gonna you're
in the paralyzed state right so this is
this is a similar type of of reading
paralysis right you're you're
experiencing this while reading while
not actually literally experiencing it
and some of the activation of our brains
different parts of our brains different
networks in our brains is surprisingly
long lasting some of it just happens
while you're reading it some of it lasts
longer this is a very complicated figure
and I didn't make it but on its but it's
always hard to try to explain other
people's very complicated figures but
the thing I want to draw your attention
to it are these plots here the brains
are distracting I know but the plots
this is a correlation between activity
the activity that you're doing and these
different circuits that are highlighted
here firing be lighting up in the in the
imagery and what we see is that on the
left this is the perspective-taking
network and when you read the story so
that so in this in this capacity in this
experiment people went in everyday and
and has these things measured they read
a story for a week and they and they
were measured then and then they were
measured after reading the story
well and what we see is that that the
correlation goes up it's significant
it's a big difference it may not look
dramatic but it goes up and this is the
perspective taking networks of the brain
that are lighting up while reading the
story what's remarkable is that this on
the other hand is the somatosensory
cortex this is that that bit about the
lived experience of the characters and
while it's it certainly goes up and it
actually looks like it goes up a little
more dramatically it stays up it stays
up for days sometimes as much as weeks
and so this suggests that there's a
there's a powerful embodiment that goes
on when you read stories that you're
engaged in and I think that this is the
sort of thing that if we're gonna think
instrumentally about using fiction these
are the sorts of things that we have to
look for what are the things that have
lasting impact I have some more ideas
about the perspective taking but I'll
never finish if I don't the amazing
thing is it's not just changes in our
own brain so when we read a story it
turns out that when I tell a story and
you listen to this story again if you're
engaged our brains actually will sync up
and this is part of this this this
amazing sociality that we have and and
the fact that our intelligence is tied
to being social Yury hands Hassim at
princeton has done amazing work showing
that people the same regions what so
they put them in in functional scanners
right and they look at that what regions
are firing and people will synchronize
what's happening the storyteller and the
and the listener to the story and this
is a remarkable feature I think it goes
way back to that really interest me is
that the this notion of distributed
context
mission right and this is an idea that
the anthropologist at UCSD Edwin
Hutchins coined in the 80s and he was
studying the amazing South Pacific
navigators here we've got some
navigators uh some sailors in the
Trobriand Islands where he worked you
know these guys would set out and and
the the the chance of you just randomly
going out and finding an island and the
Pacific are pretty infinitesimal and
these guys did it all the time and they
did it through a remarkable coordination
of what Hutchins then coined as this
distributed cognition which he then took
to study the the the bridges of aircraft
carriers and and and flight crews and
the sorts of things so I feel like
there's some really interesting
neuroscience lurking here to talk about
about coordination of behavior in
getting people literally on the same
team to solve common problems here
alright I was 15 feet from this guy but
I was safely in in a land rover right if
I had not been I would have been a
little stressed out right my adrenal
cortex would have been squirting out
cortisol the stress hormone right as I
saw this guy this is this is an adaptive
response we undergo some sort of acute
stressor our adrenal glands go into
action they squirt cortisol we get in a
physiological state - that prepares us
for the sorts of things that were likely
to have to do to adapt to the stressor
okay one of the truly remarkable things
about reading a story is that and again
when you're engaged when you're engaged
with the story you get a major
activation of your HPA access your
hypothalamus pituitary adrenal axis this
is the classic stress response
it's the the system that regulates
stress but it's also essential in the
control of the immune system mood and
sexuality and energy right now and I
think that this is this is the
foundation the physiological foundation
of that feeling when you're engaged in a
story and you're really nervous I mean
reading flight behavior I'm just so
anxious about what's gonna happen to
Delta for Rovia again you know because
what new humiliation of being poor in
America is she gonna have to endure
right and and it's that feeling of
needing to turn the page this is this
activation of the HPA axis okay it's
cool is it useful instrumentally and I
have to give props out to my Stanford
colleague Robert Sapolsky many of you
are probably familiar but he's an
incredible incredible public speaker and
and a just a huge intellect it was has
been a good mentor to me why do we care
about cortisol other than it's kind of
cool that you get this physiological
response to reading a story it turns out
that stress opens people's minds to
behavior change the right kind of stress
opens people's minds to behavior change
University College London psychologist
neuroscientist Tali Shiro is most famous
she has a fairly recent book on changing
people's minds and she's quite famous
for her her technical work on what's
called a positivity bias okay so that
you're you're faced with with
information that comes at you from the
world
you have priors prior beliefs about what
the world is like and when you get
information that's good news relative to
your desires you take that you say good
my hypothesis is supported and when you
get bad news you kind of ignore it you
don't pay as much attention to it which
seems a little paradoxical it seems like
first arrival algorithm you'd want to
learn more from bad news that's the way
I think about these things but it turns
out that isn't the way a lot of people
go about doing it until you put them
under stress when you put people under
stress when you give them some sort of
like one of these psychologists sort of
like funny things that you do you tell
them that they're gonna have to give a
public lecture after they do your test
or something like that it turns out you
open people's minds to both good news
and bad news and they behave like proper
Bayesian they update their priors in a
rational kind of way
isn't that cool and that means that
they've had their HPA access activated
it means that they're there got that
cortisol response and that's exactly
what good fiction does to you is it
possible that there's a physiological
foundation for good fiction changing
people's valence bias right there their
willingness to accept good and bad news
it's a hypothesis I want to talk about
one last thing before wrapping up which
is some really cool work that I've
encountered by a couple political
scientists Inga Hassan and Bill
Cunningham I think housen Cunningham
2014 and I was looking for pictures that
I could use to highlight cultish ness my
name is Jamie Jones right James
it's my given name many people would go
with Jim but I'm a certain vintage such
that Jim Jones turns out to be let's
just say you don't want to take kool-aid
from me no one ever did and I thought
about putting a Jim Jim but I just feel
like it's kind of in bad taste but
there's there's a remarkable body of
psychological research that deals with
what people do and and and you know you
tend to associate this with millenarian
cults you know the end is nigh it's
going to the world is going to end
On January 29th at 9 p.m. we've got 40
minutes people right and then it doesn't
end right and that seems like it would
be devastating for your belief system
right but it turns out amazingly it
usually isn't and so how can that
possibly be and that that's actually
really bad news if we're trying to
change people's minds in an instrumental
way okay so the the cool work that
they've done and it relates to my
interest in decision science and
uncertainty they have this model it's my
only like sort of academic II model here
it turns out that when you have a lot of
uncertainty and bear in mind we have a
ton of uncertainty about climate change
we have real epistemic uncertainty about
what's going to happen right what the
magnitude of things is we have a lot of
real scientific uncertainty we also have
a climate as it were we're highly
motivated groups of people are trying to
increase the uncertainty right they want
to really highlight the fact just like
the cigarette companies the tobacco
companies did the oil companies now are
trying to highlight the uncertainty so
we have uncertainty and then the
question is is there a threat this is
how do you how do people respond to
uncertainty if there is no threat it
turns out that your brain opens up and
you're willing to explore new ideas if
you are threatened if you're very and
the threat here is about the threat to
your identity right the threat to your
core identity if your core identity is
threatened if people say you know the
world didn't end and your cult says it
was going to you say oh well are praying
worked and we've gotten a reprieve so
we're gonna keep doing what we've been
doing and you guys should probably do it
too defensive close-mindedness okay so
this is another reason I think why we
need to think about the
inheritance we put out there and
associate with climate change do do we
want them all to be about you know there
not being any landmass on on the earth
do we want them to be about a fiery
hellscape i we can be realistic but we
want to think carefully about how we use
fear as a tool for motivating people
because fear frequently leads to
retrenchment so let me just wrap up by
talking about you know the three things
I just love it
you know here we are we're right right
in star basic at Starfleet Academy I
mean it's got to be like right next door
right I guess it's in the Marin
Headlands but whatever you know so so I
look I just said science fiction climate
fiction allows us to imagine better
worlds and we're not going to work
towards a better world if we can't
imagine a better world so let's get out
there and tell stories about the
possibility of our human futures some
climate change or the climate fiction is
really good for shared experience god
man remember remember when I went when I
the day I learned Tony Bourdain died I
went and slurp some fun drank some beer
down in Sunnyvale because there's no
such thing in Palo Alto and I thought
long and hard about the scene that's so
beautiful
shared experience right fiction stories
narratives they allow us to put together
a shared experience and this is another
really important thing about convincing
people about that you're right and
they're wrong but you know you'd think
you want to focus on on the facts that
you differ on in fact what you really
want to do is focus on the things that
you agree on once you establish a
rapport of a shared experience that's
when you can begin to do the hard work
of negotiating people's differences
okay so fictional out gives us a
mechanism for inducing these shared
experiences and then more speculatively
robert with his baboon friend stress
opens your mind to different types of
information and if we can write engaging
narratives that get people turning pages
and get people caring about the
characters we might have a hope of
actually getting rid of some of these
cognitive biases that seem to get in the
way of taking real action on climate
change I try to be an optimistic person
but I have to admit it's hard sometimes
and I find Graham Chi's idea here really
motivating written from an Italian
prison cell right pessimal pessimism of
the intellect you know imagine the
worst-case scenario but optimism of will
well you have to imagine that future
because the the alternative really isn't
so great and I want to end just with
with Ursula Gwyn who is so unbelievably
tied up I can't even begin to tell you
how tied up she is and so much of what
I've said in weird ways that you don't
even know but she says I think hard
times are coming when we'll be wanting
the voices of writers who can see
alternatives to how we live now and can
see through our fear stricken Society
and it's obsessive technologies to other
ways of being and even imagines some
real grounds for hope we will need
writers who can remember freedom poets
visionaries the realists of a larger
reality amen Thanks
Thank You Jamie
we we only we don't have too much time
but I thought at this point a great
thing to have would be to ask one of our
favorite science fiction writers in
recent long now speaker Han and Rajini
Mia's here an actual science fiction
writer in the real world who would be a
round of applause and maybe you've got a
couple chairs if you're up for it to
chat a little bit with Jamie Jamie thank
you so much for a very passionate and
wonderful talk what was it was the
shared experience or was it the stress
of sitting in the front row so
beautifully to our evolutionary past as
well as well how and I think nothing
could be appropriate if we we use this
superpower that evolution has given us
for thinking about the future to
actually you know save our evolutionary
future just a few thoughts thoughts
though you emphasized a lot there all of
the novel or or yeah prose and fiction
and of course I completely agree with
you that it's a very very powerful
medium and perhaps unique in the sense
that it gives us this interior T of of
another person yeah yeah puts us
directly inside their heads but of
course there are many people in the
world who do not read novels and and and
there has been this slow decline of yeah
of the literary literary novel in in
terms of popularity and so it's sort of
I'd be curious to hear your thoughts on
what other mediums
could be more accessible more powerful
and in computer games come to come to
mind to me to me given that we are
dealing with complex systems and games
are an inherently systemic medium where
you can tweak
and play with things and of course they
put us directly right in the center
center of action so so just wondering if
you have any any thoughts on that
no I do and that's a great point you
know that that there is not a giant
reading public and this is one of the
facts that I think actually argues for
the importance of continuing on the
science fiction element of life I which
is that there's always the hope if you
write some really great like just
completely like bitching story about
dragons and climate change and
spaceships coming to earth or whatever
that HBO is gonna make the next game of
Thrones right I mean the reach of that
would be extraordinary and I would love
to see people in the visual media I
don't know what you call that movies and
TV shows you know more engaged with this
it's another point that's sort of a side
point I'll get to more of what you were
asking about if you look at
representations of scientists and if you
look at representations of civil
servants in movies they're almost across
the board negative and and one of the
remarkable things about well there are a
couple remarkable things about the movie
arrival is is that amy adams from jeremy
renner or unmitigated heroes right and
they're real academics they're real
scientists in there and and Renner I
mean it's it's kind of an amazing thing
he actually learned something from the
physicists learned something from the
linguist and he's like yeah you've got
it right and I mean there's there's a
lot to be said for that type of
representation I think we need a lot
more of it it's also remarkable that
they made that incredible short story
into a movie and it was a good movie
regarding videogames I'm not a gamer but
I think that there's a lot to be said
there my concern is that it it it it
reaches a very specific audience still
like it isn't abroad I mean lots of
people play games but they this tends to
be middle-class mostly white kids in
you know the US and Europe and and and
you know those are people we need to we
need to reach absolutely it would be
cool to figure out how we could get this
this technology more broadly used my
colleague at Stanford Jeremy bailenson
does virtual reality work on sort of
giving people experiences in in
environmental situations you know he you
go into his lab and you go like this and
you can feel your hand chopping down a
tree and it turns out that people like
trees more afterwards so I think that
there's a lot of amazing potential it
would be great to figure out how we
could make it as broad as possible
though that's probably good for that
question yeah no absolutely and I think
the book even the paper book remains
like this incredible cheap medium that
doesn't wear any power and that can can
I reach reach everywhere another thing I
found myself thinking about was what
would it be like to write a story from
the point of view of a climate change
skeptic so sort of like those those very
fundamentalist Christian movies where it
has it have an atheist character who
then experiences a miraculous conversion
or maybe no I was curious if there there
has been any neuroscientific research on
how people react the story is about
about characters who have very opposite
views to to themselves or does that they
are too different from me that's a great
question I wish I knew the answer to
that and I'll have to look more I solar
right
who wrote solar McEwan Ian McEwan I my
sense is that there's a there's an
element of that in in solar it's a
really cool idea and it would be the
sort of thing so some of you may have
seen Chas Ataris talk here at the
interval and she's really interested in
in in she's more on the like the the you
know lab psychology sort of end of this
trying to figure out what are the
elements of stories that get people to
want to take action
and on on climate related issues and
this seems like the sort of thing that
would be really ripe for Chaz or people
people she's working with to to take up
like do you get a measurable effect of
having an antagonist actually make a
conversion and maybe one one final
question would be real quick is what do
you think are best examples of fiction
really changing people's minds historic
yeah if you have any favorite favorite
examples of that kind my wife is a Civil
War historian and Uncle Tom's Cabin has
got to be you know the I mean it's it's
the it's the prototype for this type of
socially relevant literature you know
it's not great literature right it's
it's kind of a small tea story but it
man it had a big effect my daughter has
been suggesting to me that The Grapes of
Wrath is is a sort of early climate
fiction you know you've got these these
displaced people they're moving bodies
across a landscape they're they're
fleeing largely a climatic event and you
see they're they're just horrible lives
they lead and the consequences of this
broken environment I don't know if that
had its intended effect another
interesting one is is Upton Sinclair's
the jungle you know you're writing about
the meatpacking industry and what's
interesting and this is something that
Michaels cautioned me on a couple times
you know the unintended consequences
right they're complex systems we can't
we don't know with different initial
conditions we might get different
results and Sinclair was writing this
book you know from the perspective of
the workers when people read it they got
really upset about the the food that
like the house safe the food was it's
like well yeah that too but also the
workers uh-huh so those are a couple
examples I mean you know something like
Rachel Carson's Silent Spring it isn't
really fiction but I mean it starts off
with with
a scenario right I mean I think if we
thought hard about it we could come up
with a lot of these things but as I said
I'm not a literary guy honey before you
well we've got you up here so most of
your published work hasn't been focused
on commenting there's some you know if
he thinks in there but but I think you
said you've got something that you have
worked on and you've looked at I'm
curious but what have you thought about
and what attracts you as far as aspects
around climate change to to write about
you've thought about or might be working
on and also as a reader because you've
probably read more science fiction and
the two of us put together
what are some of the things that you've
seen authors do in a Clive I space that
that stand out to you and and why I'm
really just dabbling deviling in the
sphere right now I have a novella I've
been working on for a while on and off
which I which I actually hope to finish
sometime this year called brothers milk
which touches upon very much the the
human mobility and survival aspects
there there's this pop up Village Inn or
pop-up city in the certified southern
Italy with with various displaced
peoples trying trying to survive there's
a there's a political entity that they
have to deal with called the the green
Caliphate which is radicalized Islam
which is also very very very very pro
environment and so I'm kind of kind of
interested in in paradoxical or
seemingly contradictory combinations of
ideologies that could emerge in in some
of these possible futures in terms of
what I what I've seen I think Jamie did
a great job of mentioning a few examples
I also think short stories in general
are a great format or for science
fiction in general and there's a few
anthologies there's a this one one I
really like called Solar Punk which
solar Punky's
some people have given to to a hopeful
more Wi-Fi genre so so I recommend you
check out that one there's an older
anthology that that has similar themes
called shine which is more broader than
than climate but also does a great job
of outlining some very optimistic and
engaging engaging futures so so there's
some some examples that's great there's
the new one that just came out the new
anthology like literally came out today
I got all about it so yes Arizona State
some friends of ours Arizona State
University let us know and we'll be
posting this on our social media for for
long now it just came out today it's
free a downloadable ebook it's actually
the second edition that they've done
both have been actually fiction writing
contests that have been judged by
science fiction writers Kim Stanley
Robinson be at this latest one and it
looks really cool and blanking on the
name right now but we'll put it out
there and like I said it's free so
definitely check that out I'll give you
a big round of applause to honey thank
you so much Adam
[Applause]
and and we do want to sneak in we're
running a little bit over but we do want
to sneak in a couple of your questions
so Roseanne's got the the mic please get
her attention I wanted to ask you so so
the it's interesting that people need to
be under stress to to open up the
possibility of switching tracks as it
were and change change the amount of
this stuff is massive fear of climate
change gonna bring us all into that
state if I mean I guess I guess maybe
one of the things that I'm in forward is
that and and someone has said this I'm
sorry not to be able to fully quote it
but all fiction is going to be climate
fiction in the very near future because
it's going to be more of a reality that
we're dealing with it and it are so
familiar and so salvaged the bones which
is about Katrina the wake of Katrina
anything that's dealing with some of
these massive
does that weather disasters are
inherently doing that and in a way you
know we didn't I don't think I think we
touched on Stan's notion Kim Stanley
Robinson's notion of the of looking at
both the present time and looking at a
possible future but but in a way those
two so any any future that we're looking
at is also reflecting in a moment that
where we're in and as those two in near
near-term future sci-fi or Clive I our
super close inherently work probably
gonna identify with those people Moore's
is one of the other conditions to think
and any thoughts on that lots of
thoughts yeah I mean it's dangerous to
write about the near-term right it's
harder in a lot of ways if you write
about people 3,000 years in the future
but for all we know we've sprouted wings
by that point we can fly to the stars
right where's there has to be enough
continuity if you're writing about say
20 50 years in the future that it seems
realistic and that the the feel of it is
right but but a lots gonna change so
it's it's a I think it's a real
technical challenge for the futurist and
I completely agree that you know
Margaret out would write said it's not
climate change it's everything change
and and when when the the world is in
these tightly coupled systems you know
you throw something big at the sort of
top level system it's going to have
cascading effects and ramify affects not
just cascading this and coming down but
Rama fiying is in going side to side and
having just huge effects so I yeah we if
we want to write about the present
anytime from now to the future the
climate background has probably got to
be in there we've got a question right
here there we go so so so also related
to this stress thing one of the common
things just in talking about climate is
to give people a few little things they
can do to release their stress and you
know and so without having the stress of
thinking about the big picture or even
seeing the system so I wonder if just
sort of in the generic kind of climate
community conversation if you have
thoughts about the jump to give people
little solutions if that's a short
circuiting of that stress or how would
you how do you how do you perceive that
yeah I mean this is another thing that
telly sure talks about is giving people
empowering people and feeling like they
have some control and that they're much
more willing to sort of engage in
behavior change if they feel like they
have control so I think that that's a
really important an important feature of
any sort of strategy for getting people
to take action I mean I guess the
concern is you want the things that
people do to feel like they're in
control to be meaningful and and you
know if if like I feel good about
recycling plastic but you know China
isn't taking plastic anymore and so it's
actually ending up in the in the ocean
you know the might be somewhat
self-defeating there so yeah absolutely
and I and that actually you're
mentioning stress reminded me of the
other part of your question that you
know Robert Sapolsky talks at length
about the difference between chronic and
acute stress right now acute stress is
the stuff that's good for us it's what
it's why we exercise it's why we read
fiction and get engaged and why we like
that why we keep going back to it and
you know just constant doom and gloom
I'm all for realism but the constant
doom and gloom that puts us under this
continual chronic stress is is not the
way to change people's behavior so
getting kind of a bolt up and experience
at a singular experience yeah as opposed
to being terrorized as a person a
low-grade constant terror right yeah
right how's everybody feeling out there
tonight we got another question over
here anything hi thanks so people often
don't feel stress unless they're in the
situation sister
seems more less effective as a proactive
rather than a reactive approach I'm not
sure how effective stress would be as
like premeditated and then the second
part of my question is you tie in a lot
about evolutionary psychology as a way
to kind of help people resonate with the
story so that they take action on it but
evolutionary psychology and natural
selection I mean most people take the
path of least resistance and most people
are selfish how is that how can you
leverage and utilize that for something
like advocating for social good like
climate change yeah it's a great
question I I guess I would challenge the
the idea that were were fundamentally
selfish there that there's there's an
enormous body of research that that's
building right now talking about the the
fact that and so so people who've talked
about this you know Sam Bowles has has a
recent book on this he's an economist
and I wish I could remember the name of
it it's a fabulous book on on basically
arguing that that that economic
incentives aren't enough to encourage
good behavior but it turns out the good
news is that people actually want to
engage in good behavior people are per
social under the rights under the right
circumstances and so I I guess that
that's the key right it's to make it
under the right circumstances people
have to be engaged in their communities
it also helps if you don't tell them
that you know that people are
fundamentally these neoliberal agents
who are who are constantly out there
trying to maximize their economic
utility and say yeah actually there's
there's a place for for social good and
for morality in these sort of things so
I actually find the the current work in
in in evolutionary studies very hopeful
in that regard I'm sorry the first part
of your question oh oh right and this is
the amazing thing about about the this
about the certain neuroscience of
reading stories
and watching stories and it's something
I'd like to see a more robust literature
on like that we need more research on
this because you know we were
simultaneously as I'm telling you about
all these cool results of neuroscience
I'm also dealing with the fact that
there's this thing called the
replication crisis or the replicability
crisis right that 85% of medical studies
are underpowered and you can't be
replicated and it's about the same for
psychology as well right so it would be
nice to have a more robust sort of body
of work saying this but from what I can
tell the the there is there's strong
evidence that the the the reading of a
story the telling of a story the the
comprehension of a story puts you in
that state that's as though you're
experiencing it obviously a little safer
right you're not you don't have that
lion right there but it it seems to me
like that's promising for putting you in
the state for changing being open to
changing your mind Thanks all gonna be
able to have four questions right now
but you're gonna stick around and and
there was a line oh there's a lot that
we didn't even touch on and background
on what's there so I hope you'll stick
around I want to give a quick shout out
first of all to borderlands who are in
the back those are her in the room
everyone here knows they covered our
chime generator table with like
literally dozens of books and and
probably close to two dozen titles or
more of climate fiction of various sorts
that's the list that you've been
compiling and in dialogue with
borderlands to some extent you are gonna
be publishing that let's just on your
blog and we'll be sending it out there
so keep an eye out for that I also want
to mention so Susan Ataris talk which
you mentioned is is on our website on
the interval site we'll also send out a
link to that and you mentioned Jeremy
bailenson Vincent's work at Stanford
about VR and empathy and Kara Plutonian
for us we she talks a bit about that
work in her talk that she gave for us
and a couple of the things you talked
about I think we're going to be talking
about late
this year as well so keep an eye on on
what we're doing here for this Jamie as
far as this work goes and what you're
thinking about next and I mean I can't
just put it in context again I mean this
is not your your your primary work it's
very much kind of a passion project that
brings some of your work into other
other interests so are you gonna
continue this is this is this what do
you do you have a sense of what the life
of this is gonna be I have a feeling it
could take over my life if I'm not
careful I'm sure honey who has thoughts
on that I don't know I mean yeah maybe
you know I have this unpublishable paper
right that I've been working on III
write it I was like where the hell am I
gonna publish this my god because it's
not an essay like fur I don't know the
Atlantic or something some sort of but
it's it's it's it's kind of academic but
it's like not theirs so I don't know
we'll see what the reception is I guess
I think I respond to positive
reinforcement all right well well I
think we can get a bunch of that again
but I have to say this is also kind of
the fourth kind of my favorite talk on
top of the other three that I mentioned
earlier and it's the kind of talk is
like I've had a homeroom remember that
talk about client climate science
fiction yeah yeah but but remember that
one talk about the guy who is really
into gonorrhea the the eclecticism of
this talk in and of itself people
realize the later they're talking about
the same talk can we get some positive
reinforcement for tonight's speaker
please
and and as Jamie knows because he keeps
coming back here we have a long now
challenge coin for you as a thank you
for being here
I knew I'm gonna give you your second
one for her bravely stepping up here and
and because you're a three-time ER and I
want to do something a little bit
special this is a Stuart brand
autographed copy of the clock of the
long now did he sign for you so you know
just just to encourage you all to hit
the triple crown here interval as well
one more big round of applause and thank
you guys for coming out very nice
[Applause]
[Music]